thank you go now so my name is Sophia
escorting household nikova and I'm from
Penn State and this year and I'm on
sabbatical at Boston University um many
types of data can be represented as
graphs how where nodes correspond to
individuals and edges capture
relationships between them examples
include friendships and online social
networks financial transactions email
communication health networks romantic
relationships and so on so for this
audience I don't have to argue that we
have to be careful when we publish
information about this type of data as
much as we're careful when we're
publishing information about other types
of data in so no talk on privacy and
graphs is complete without this picture
so let me ask who has not seen that or
who's seen this picture before not
everybody okay so let me just mention so
this is a picture of a social network of
romantic relationships in a real
American high school published as is in
a famous sociological study so they
stripped all obviously identifying
information and so the but they kept
completely the graph structure and the
genders of the notes of the of the
people and I guess since most people
actually saw this graph before I'm not
going to spend much time talking about
it I'm just going to point out some
nodes which are very unique in the graph
so this is one node this is another node
and in fact there are lots of unique
looking nodes in this network and more
generally it's been pointed out that in
social networks if you look at small
neighborhood of a node it will uniquely
identify the note and it has been used
to down anonymize naively anonymized
social networks so we'll have to be
careful obviously one with published
information about grass
so you might ask who who we want to die
Nana mais a social network Oh NSA um
maybe fishers and spammers to make
messages to you more believable and
personalizable maybe Harvin Mariana
there are definitely people out there
who try to do this and published attacks
on social networks and again I'm not
going to focus on this at all i just
want to mention that they exist and at
the high level basically you can read
into fine dividuals I Navy identified
namely anonymize social network and most
of the things work on using information
from external sources okay so what are
we going to do about it so again put
this crowd I'm not going to argue that
we need a rigorous definition and so
we're going to use differential privacy
and differential privacy in graphs is
defined the same way as for databases so
the only difference is so our input is a
graph right so otherwise everything
looks exactly the same so the only thing
I haven't specified here is neighbors
right so where the condition of
differential privacy holds for two
neighboring databases in this case the
neighboring data data sets are graphs
and I have to say what i mean by
neighbors so there are two natural
notions of neighbors and graphs and they
correspond to two variants of
differential privacy as differential
privacy and no differential privacy let
me ask who has not seen this before take
it and so I'll go over it so so the
first first definition corresponds to
notion of neighbors where the graphs
actually our neighbors that they differ
in exactly one edge rate so just go
through the whole definition so it gives
you a differential privacy and naturally
so no differential privacy corresponds
to the notion of neighbors were
to grab some neighbors if they can one
can be obtained from the other by aids
in your removing and node and its
adjacent edges so no differential
privacy is more in this period of
protecting privacy of each individual
but naturally it's harder to obtain
because you have to protect you have to
safeguard against much larger changes in
your data okay so in both cases we have
two conflicting goals utility and
privacy and for even simplest statistics
on grabs it turns out that is impossible
to get both in the worst case so we're
going to try to achieve this
differential differentially private
algorithms that are accurate unrealistic
yes so we're not going to give up
privacy our algorithms are going to be
private on all graphs but we have to
then give up accuracy on some graphs and
we're going to choose the graphs on
which our algorithms work well carefully
so our algorithms are going to be
awkward for subclass of graphs and
differentially private photographs ok so
what grab statistics are we going to
consider so we'll look at simple graph
statistics number of edges accounts of
small sub graphs so for example triangle
to triangle in the graph is a free click
like this k triangles so it's a
bipartite graph sorry that's not by
predict so it's an edge connected to a
bunch of nodes and it would be bipartite
if you remove this edge and key stars so
our nodes were which are connected to
the other nodes degree distribution the
degree distribution is a vector where
for each degree in the graph will
specify the fraction of nodes which have
the degree so some other things that
have been said
look at lots of metrics and so this free
i'm going to focus on today but let me
just mention other than things that
people who looked at so cut sizes so cut
sizes just given a cut in the graph how
many ages cross it distance the nearest
graph with a certain property and people
look at other things that maybe i'll
mention later joined a redistribution
sorry i had more so let me mention so
what was known so there's a number of
papers that came out in 2003 and so let
me mention what was known prior to 2030
2013 so this is edged differentially
private algorithms before this year and
so grab statistics for which they work
and the corresponding techniques that
were used so we knew how to release the
number of triangles and the cost of the
minimum spanning tree and the technique
there was a smooth and steady so i'm
just going to go over it is just gonna
mention to give you a feeling for what's
known and then i'm going to get into
details about some algorithms so we know
how to degree a release degree
distribution and so the idea is there
you can just use global sensitivity and
then the whole ingenuity goes into post
processing and there's been several
methods which were suggested on how to
process the data in order to remove some
of the noise and they're quite ingenious
and actually work well in real leah
releasing small sub graph pounds so it's
based on smoothing city and variant of
proposed test and release for cuts so
this two lines of work have incomparable
guarantees so the first one is based on
random projections on global sensitive
and there are the guarantees for every
card so firstly for specific pad with
high probability you get some bounds on
the noise in the answer and so in this
method
dates you you'll have a guarantee for
all grab for all cuts with high
permeability and so here there is more
noise that's considered the gate so
there i'm just going to mention things
without of explaining them just to give
you a feeling that there there is work
going on so there's been work on
Kronecker draft model parameters and if
i understand correctly that's based on
post processing also sorry there there
so i found lots of papers which mention
differential privacy and graphs and
since i wanted me to actually say this
still like a project for some of them
basically there is actually no rigorous
explanation like I couldn't find Regulus
explanation what's going on in the paper
so I just didn't include them but some
papers I just I guess then probably
didn't find or don't don't I'm not aware
of so there's lots of work on graphs and
differential privacy or at least people
are aware of it and trying to do this
and some some papers actually are just
saying strange things you can ask me in
person over there I'm very saying so
there are other definitions besides the
two definitions which are in kind of
most often used so let me mention them
so there is an edge private against
Beijing adversary's so it's the weaker
definition then differential privacy and
so they released small sub graph towns
by but in 2009 but by now we know how
how to release sub graph pounds with
differential privacy of a stronger
privacy definition with less noise than
was not in this paper there is no 0 node
privacy which is in principle it's a
stronger privacy guaranteed and
differential privacy and so there is an
edge version in note version and so in
this paper so they define from this and
there's lots of nice work that goes into
definitions there and kind of
understanding them and so what they i'll
put the average degree which is
basically the same as
wedges distances to nearest connected
graph you live in grafton cycle-free
graphs and so there the idea is so they
used up in your time albums and then use
global sensitive a framework and the
kind of it's the main restriction there
so they actually talk about node 0 0 no
0 knowledge privacy but they assume that
their graph is bounded degree so the
give privacy only for about the bounded
degree grabs and so in basically if you
have privacy for it with respect to
edges in most cases it's kind of easy to
get privacy for bounded degree grabs
right because in bout the Google Apps
you're just changing your few pages so
they very definition is so which they
achieve is actually we / than no
differential privacy oh and i wanted to
mention so there there are other papers
so for example is the Christine here
Chris didn't ask yes of her paper on
outlink privacy I guess you can talk to
her about it so the model there is a
slightly different so it's it's not that
you're given the graph in advance the
algorithm accesses the graph by
surveying people and just getting
partial information about the graph and
then the model is not entirely clear to
me so maybe you can talk to Christina
you have questions about that okay so so
hopefully I gave you an overview of
what's been going on before 2013 so in
2013 there are three papers that came
out basically almost at the same time so
in the Indus work and they propose new
techniques and they achieve differential
privacy for no differential privacy and
which some papers claimed before that
was probably impossible to achieve
also if you use the techniques you can
get better educational private albums so
what I'm going to focus on today is this
the techniques that are proposed in this
papers and please feel free to stop me
and ask questions so this papers
actually give provide guarantees for
resulting algorithms so there's four mo
utility analysis they're actually in the
last two papers so they so again the
algorithms are no differentially private
for all graphs they're accurate for sub
grass subclass of graphs which includes
bounded degree graphs where the degree
bond is not necessarily constant just
some souvenir bond perhaps were the tail
of the degree distribution is not too
heavy i'm going to explain that just
just leave it informal and deads graphs
so i'm not going to be talking much
about utility event is today just i had
to pick what to talk about but i guess
there is utility analysis in mr. papers
sorry in the in a second in the first
paper yes and this this is not a paper
yet it's just that i wanted to explain
the newer Algrim bill and there are some
experiments that have been done with the
salga rooms and they perform so the
performance is promising and rail graphs
for very simple statistics so what I'm
going to focus on today is no
differentially private algorithms for
releasing this like simplest kinds of
statistics number of edges pounds of
small sub graphs and also the degree
distribution the distribution is a
little different because it's just it's
not just one number that you have to
release its a whole vector so have to
think about it low and mostly what I'm
going to be focusing on is this new
technics so there are three techniques
that I'm going to try to explain if I
get to it so the first one is truncation
plasma sensitivity the second one is
Lipschitz extensions and the third one
is recursive mechanism and so truncation
plasma sense to do so
very and that was proposed in block e at
all and also in our paper with but he is
here from block people I guess it was
too early for said that he might be here
and in our paper with a hobby and a
Shiva and Adam and also different
extensions to some variant investment
proposed in both papers and recursive
mechanism is a paper which I guess I
just discovered for myself and I'll try
to like I don't know why it's called
recursive mechanism and I changed all
other names but they give the things but
this one I didn't change its ending with
you so the unifying idea is some kind of
projections on graphs with low
sensitivity and actually everything here
should be in quotes projections and
grabs and sensitivity also like depends
what you mean intensity so that's kind
of the unifying idea and so I'll try to
present as much as I can get to like so
for things the generic reductions to
privacy / bounded degree graph so as I
mentioned bounded degree graphs somehow
seems easier to achieve once once you
have edge privacy and so this uses the
first method truncation and SMO studious
so much the city so I will just briefly
mention what's going on there and will
not go into detail so then releasing
number of edges and sub graph accounts
using lips it's extension me a maximum
flow and linear programming so i will
explain what's going on there and then
releasing degree distribution so it's
also the ellipses extensions via convex
programming i'll also try together and
this recursive mechanism so i'll explain
it on an example of releasing grass
subtract pounds but the probability
papers face very generally and i guess i
don't quite understand the the ceiling
of what it can achieve and i think it's
very interesting technique and kind of
different looking a little bit from
other things we've tried okay so let's
try to 12 into technical details so the
basic question we're trying to answer so
we're given a graph so there is some
it's stored in some trusted place and so
the users ask a question so they asked
for some statistics and
they get some approximation f of g and
the question is how accurately can an
epsilon differentially private album
release f of g and specifically again so
i'm going to be presenting this new
techniques as they apply to note privacy
but you can also apply them to edge
privacy and in some places given
modifications are very clear what you
need to do just and fled as last knows
just because you won a differential
privacy ok so what were what is the
challenge for node privacy so why it
took a while for us to think of first
algorithms which we have knowed private
albums so one of the thing is things is
that basically in the worst case working
on Gedman good noise but it's true also
about edge privacy so here things seem
to be a little more challenging so so
global sensitivity so I hope most people
so we seen so many times that most
people are used to the notion so I'm
going to denote it by Delta F so and
node global sensitivity so it's the
maximum how much can i change the value
of my function if i go from this
database to a neighboring database mean
the grab that differs in one node and
all adjacent edges so here examples so
for them so i'm going to denote the
number of edges like this and the number
of triangles like this so what's the
global sensitivity of the number of
edges in the graph so basically if i go
to a neighboring graph from a graph with
n nodes so by by how much can i change
the number of edges so this turns out to
be the worst thing you can do wait to
read node connected to everybody so the
global sensitivity of the number of
edges is M hey so for the number of
triangles so again the worst thing you
can do is add a node connected to
everybody so it turns out that the
global society of number of triangles is
anxious to are there any questions
everybody is happy with us you see
you're going to get a better talk out of
media's questions what it's like it's
fine okay um so this is a global
sensitivity notion so
thing is so global sensitivity is high
for this quantities right so what you
know just especially for sparse graph so
social networks we're talking about
social networks we cannot use our
familiar Laplace mechanism and just add
noise according to global sense TV
moreover this notion of local
sensitivity which we so was defined with
its red and have reference here so with
pivot papered with Kobe and Adam until
which we kind of used as our guideline
in edge privacy is also high so it turns
out you can not just add noise
proportional to local sensitivity but
you can strive to be kind of
proportional to it in terms of how you
add noise and be compatible with it on
good graphs right so this is the local
sensitivity which way it is but I'm not
going to be using it so it's not
important that you understand the
definition carefully so there is a new
measure of sensitivity which proposed
which is proposed in the recursive
mechanism paper by chen zhao which i
call down sensitivity so as i said they
changed their names so it's a basically
how much can i change the function by
going from the graph that i'm given from
the specific graph and removing a note
and adjacent edges wait so here I am
allowed to do any operation room
overhead here I'm only allowed to remove
and so for graphs for for grad
statistics is especially the statistics
they were looking in this notion so this
quantity is much lower right so as i was
showing so by adding you know connected
to everybody yesterday so it's the
maximum by which i can change the value
of my function in the current graph so
i'm given graph g right so how much can
i change the value of the function at
the graph so f of g this is the value of
the function by going to a a neighbor
which is a sub graph so basically how
much can i change the value of my
function by removing a node and adjacent
edges right so in local since Teddy I'm
are allowed so I'm asking how much can i
change the value of the function by
adding or removing a node and Here I am
only allowed to remove a note
so if we look at the number in the worst
case right so but where as I said we're
not going for the worst case so for so
if we're looking at typical social
network right so what so worst case is
not achievable here if you want both
privacy and utility so if you looking at
a typical social network right so by so
as I said like so the thing that
maximizes local sensitivity I'm going to
add a node connected to everybody and so
let's say for the number of edges is
going to be the glow of the local sim
city up is n but so how much can I
change how many ages can I change by
removing your note so it's the degree
right so the actual degree of the
largest node larger security nagar so it
could be much less wait till and the
same format for but number of triangles
gets even more drastic because it's dumb
sensitivities what's the largest number
of number of triangles a single node is
involved in right so even for high
degree nodes it might not be met hi so
so I'm just giving you this a kind of a
measure to you to think about and so for
the algorithm that I'm going to present
you can actually show that basically on
good instances you are any noise raptly
proportional to this but again as I said
I'm not going to give utility analysis
but I just kind of find this measure
useful to think about so this is kind of
intuitively what we're striving to
achieve right so for the local
sensitivity so there isn'ta thought
about it as kind of a good measure is
because it can serve as a lower bound in
some sense so if you have two databases
which kind of between them this local
sensitivity is achieved then 11 of them
you have to know it know is proportional
to this local son's feeding but so the
whole idea here is that you're going to
choose carefully on which one and then
the one which is going to get typical
graph you are going to add less noise
specific so so the idea kind of
high-level idea is to project onto
graphs with load ancestors to aim in
some sense
okay so so a first example that I people
came out came up with of graphs with a
little down sensitivities graphs of
small degree so in his first two papers
the projection or silicon projections
will try to do projections on two graphs
of small degree so let G be the family
of all graphs so we're trying to be
private for for this entire family and
let G sub D be the family of graphs of
degree bond at most D so as before so
Delta of F is global sensitivity over G
and tilde sub zero vectors global
sensitivity over G sub Z over this
family and so it's not hard to observe
that even global sensitivity is low for
many useful functions f if you just
basically postulate that your graphs
always coming from low degree graphs so
coming back to our examples with a
number of edges and the number of
triangles so now the global sensitivity
is going to be d and g choose 2
respectively compared it to and an
anxious to which could be it's a lower
okay so if we're just postulate that all
our grafts have low degree we're done we
can just use global sensitivity
framework but the woman privacy for all
graphs and in fact let me also mention
that the typical social networks are not
just grabs of low degree they are close
to graphs of low degree but they
typically have some number of high
degree nodes so if we want so these are
also good graphs on which we want to do
well so in some sense we're going to try
to project from this space of all graphs
the graphs of bounded degree and so for
some carefully chosen degree bond and
this I'm going to sweep under the carpet
on how we're going to choose the degree
bond and there are some open questions
they're actually how to do it well so we
know how to do it in some way but not
clear that we know how to do it in the
best way okay so I'm going to talk try
to talk about three methods truncation
and smooth sensitivity is the first
method so again so you can think about
is reduction to privacy / bounded degree
graphs and what I'm going to explain is
a reduction from our paper with Shiva
kobian Adam but there is kind of a
reduction that achieves and a similar
thing in the paper of blocky at all so
our reduction so our truncation
operation is much simpler there is more
sophisticated so as a result we get
better running time and in terms of
noise it's not clear its incomparable
what they do but can kind of be a high
level ideas are similar okay so kind of
at the high level basically what it
achieves is for any algorithm that is no
differentially private / bounded degree
graphs so basically you can get an
algorithm that is no differentially
private over all graphs and it has
accuracy similar to the original
algorithm over nice graphs in in some
sense so the first step in understanding
no differential privacy is getting no
different to the private algorithms and
bout it to get rats and the reduction is
very efficient in terms of and and
actually it is easy to implement my son
my undergraduate student implemented it
and them so as select the other methods
do much better in terms of noise so I'm
not going to spend much more time and
such as kind of a very generic method
they're easy to implement methyl bit
early adds more noise than we would like
on really cigarettes okay so how does it
work so the idea is very simple so we're
going to project on graphs of low degree
by doing the separation T which is just
a simple truncation so we're just going
to cut out all nodes of degree large in
indy and again in block e at all they do
some more careful removal which takes
longer but then as a result they have to
add more noise and that's like my knives
in a second step okay yeah so so we
answer queries on this truncated graph
instead of the actual graph so they
scream truncated and now like what we're
going to compute the number of triangles
okay
just mentioned a paper hey I should I
appreciate it it's pretty early thank
you so we're answering questions on the
truncated grab so for example now that
we truncated graph which is going to
help with the number of triangles their
aim and so one way of doing this is just
answer queries with the smooth
sensitivity framework which I didn't
describe but it's kind of some way of
making this local sensitivity idea work
so I said you cannot add noise according
to a local sensitivity but in paper with
carbon atom so we showed how to smooth
it out and I'd know is according to and
another way of doing this is the e
proposed the test project there in this
your program to the duty sorry so I
don't always gets confusing he program
this proposed this ringing sorry and I
always love with him with no I did it do
okay we don't reject it we release it
but I guess in some talks to rejected
functions or functions are care about
right or rejected this oh hey okay
anyway so I just wanted to mention so
kind of a so the algorithm itself is
very simple again the high-level idea so
you just truncate the graph you compute
this quantity called small sensitivity
on this graph of of this truncation
operation and to get the smooth
sensitivity over over over the overall
quantity so it basically compose as well
so you can add noise according is
according to the smoothness city over
the whole operator which is just a
product of the small sensitivity
of the communication information for
this graph and the global sensitivity
with respect to about the degree graphs
of the function that you want to release
so basically this is the same just once
you have a graph you can just compute
this and then for other statistics you
just compute global sensitivity which is
easy and just release according to this
okay but I'm not going to focus on this
method because the new wall they
practice okay so let me so I'm going to
spend much more time on method to which
is Lipschitz extensions okay and this
idea was proposed in both block en el
and Khushi rush fundamental so a
function f prime is the Lipschitz
extension of F from bounded degree
graphs graphs of great most d2 general
graphs if it agrees with F on bound to
geograph Smee produces the same answers
and moreover the global sensitivity of
this new function overall is the same as
it was on the smaller set right so we
basically take so here's a picture so we
have some function where global
sensitivity is low and bounded degree
graphs and high in general and what
would you which if I a prime to be the
same on this this part and then we just
extend it to be the same to have the
same global sense City everywhere else
right then so global city is called also
called Lipschitz constant so that's why
we call it clipped its extensions ok so
here's a clear what we're trying to do
so I guess this is this definition is
good to understand because I'm going to
spend some time on this mapping
questions well that's good ok and then
so once we have this function so we're
just going to release this Lipschitz
extension via the global sensitivity
framework using the fact that it has low
global films TV and then so basically
i'm not going to prove this but on for
for the statistics we care about you
just we can just proved that when you do
the separation from graphs which are
closed to bound the decorator
you don't lose too much so the first
step when you go to shift to a prime
instead of F doesn't lose too much ok so
[ __ ] it I'll prove that there exists
Lipschitz extensions for all really
really odd functions and so Lipsius
extensions moreover can be computed
efficiently me in in polynomial time so
we show that it can be done for sub
graph counts and also for degree
distribution and i'm going to show you
this efficient Lipschitz extension and
so notice that degree distribution is
not real valued functions a vector of a
real value so even the existence of this
does not follow from from this result ok
so let's look at the ellipsis extension
for the number of edges so the heat the
ad here is to use the flow graph and if
I have time I'll show you experiments
her for this so this is a worked
actually very well even in huge graphs
so for a for grass so for given a graph
we define a flow corresponding flow
graph of G as follows so we just make
two copies of each node and two copies
of each edge it's basically we added a
edge so it's symmetric probe UV prime if
and only if UV is any hey so and then we
add a source also here we put capacities
one on all the sages and so here where
the source and capacity is deon all it
is coming out of the source and here
where the sink and capacity edges on all
coming into the source I start coming to
the sink and so now we compute we can
compute the maximum flow on this graph
and we define this at flow to be the
value of the maximum flow here so and
this is the function we're going to get
so this function which we can
efficiently compute so the claim is that
this function over two is
ellipsis extension of the number of
edges and this is easy to show I'm not
sure looking at it at least state what
we have to show this Oleg remember in
order to see that it's the Lipschitz
extension we have to show that in fact
it has the right value for bounded
degree graphs and also that the global
sensitivity in general is equal to the
global sensitivity on bounded degree
graphs so here i just multiplied
everything by 2 so who's seen this proof
before today you should repeat this
proof because yeah I guess then yeah
okay so this is actually very lazy and
just an I'm worried that I packed too
much material into the talk um okay oh
you have okay changes the picture my
vision okay so let's let's see why okay
so first let's see why the flow is
actually equals to 2 times the number of
edges in this graph so first of all
notice that we can achieve the following
flow we can just put flow of one on the
middle edges and flow corresponding to
the degree on the edges coming up out of
the source and into the sink and so this
the resulting flow is going to have 2
times the number of edges value and this
flows indeed the maximum flow because
this cut has two times the number of
edges capacity so that's the hope of
here so now let's prove that the global
sensitivity of this flow function is at
most two times the global sin city over
bounded degree grass and recorded the
global sin city over bounded degree
grabs was just D so this isn't equal to
2 D
so how we're going to show that the
global sensitivity is to do or maybe
most of d so but it is actually 2d so
we're just going to consider an
arbitrary graph and its neighbor right
so and they so we'll see what change
will get into the value of the function
on this graph and its neighbor so this
is an arbitrary graph and now when i add
one node to the graph let's see what's
going to happen to this flow graph so
I'm going to add two copies of this node
in the flow graph I'm going to add the
corresponding capacity edges and I'm
going to add the corresponding
intermediate edges here and so now by
how much can change my flow well let's
consider the size of the immune cut in
the original graph so we can extend it
to another cut which has capacity the
same as before plus 2 g right so the
maximum flow could not have increased by
more than 2 d oh sorry um yes I and
actually it's easy to show that you can
actually I chip 2d but for the purposes
of adding noise it's not even important
great so because of the mobile facility
is at most 2 D ok so that's the whole
proof so let's move on to the ellipses
extension via linear programs so this
idea can be generalized to graph counts
by using linear programs so now again
we're given a graph and we define the
corresponding of P program with
variables so let's do let's do it for
the number of triangles and then it's
easy to see how they've sent it to all
three accounts but the linear program
becomes much larger for large accounts
for counts including largest sub graphs
so we're going to define in your program
with a variable corresponding to each
triangle and what we're going to
maximize is the sum of this variables
over all triangles in the original graph
and so we're going to so this is
basically a linear program for
convenient number of friends so integer
program competing phone number triangles
which is work where we relax the value
of the variable exceed so it can be
between 0 and 1 so we're kind of
interests instead of projecting onto
grabs we're projecting on some kind of
continuous version of the graphs here
and so the interesting constraint here
is that for every node V we're going to
say that the number of triangles which
include this node shouldn't be more than
what it would have been in bounded
cigarettes so we're not going to allow
the this variable to sound to something
more than this so this is basically what
it's allowed to be in graphs of the
great bounty plea which responds to the
global sensitivity in graphs of bounded
degree D of the number of triangles and
so the function that we're interested in
is the value of this linear program it
so this this is the Lipschitz extension
and I'm not going to prove this but it's
see one can prove that this is indeed a
Lipschitz extension so the two
properties that we discussed hope
so in a different way of thinking about
it is that so if we use Delta here
instead of the Z choose to as a bound so
we don't have to put G choose to here so
it can be some other Delta and then so
what what's going to give us is a
function with global sensitive a delta
and you can think about this function is
the Lipschitz extension from some set of
graphs which also includes bounded
degree graphs for corresponding D which
which is lower than its ok to make
dishes to respond to the street but also
it includes other graphs where where
this this holds right where the number
of triangles where each each node is
involved in is at most Delta yes Danny
you can you speak up it's not going to
give you integral values but when one
year when you add noise at the end it
also there how do you know that it's
going to give you integral values and
bound in cigarettes so for bounded
degree graphs basically so just just
maximizing everything right so it's just
basically setting all variables all
triangles that exist in the graph so all
variables that you defined setting them
to one is going to maximize the linear
program right is the it's the only
maximum solution rate and the end that
you don't get an integral value so you
just you just out so you can say you can
clean it up somehow but like basically
before before you output it you still
have to add Laplace noise and it's not
going to give you an internal value
anyway and so I guess you can round it
later but so yeah there is a guarantee
on how far it is from the actual value
but it yes so in fact I guess they so I
mentioned there are like nice processing
techniques for for the
redistribution for example I me til
people so the output is of course non
integer but people came up with various
nice ideas of how to use and the fact
that you know the degree sequence has to
look a certain way that it has to be
graphical for example so vishesha is
here it's in his paper so you use this
to actually remove some of the noise so
like the fact that you have additional
constraints is good for post-processing
any other questions about this okay so
and this can be generalized to other
common queries you can basically in a
similar way constructing your programs
but they get progressively bigger and
less efficient as you look at bigger and
bigger cell grafts okay so um and next
thing I would like to explain this
delicious extension for functions for
function that outputs a vector right so
it's a little them so it's a little
different so we cannot just use this
linear program and then so namely the
function is the degree sequence sorry
this is the degree distribution yes you
can do a degree sequence but they eaten
yeah so degree distribution and guesses
let's just focus on the grade
distribution okay so and this is from
recent work with annum so and it's done
via convex programming so let's go back
to our flow graph and we're able to use
the flow graph to get an accurate
quantity with low sensitivity which was
equal to the number of edges so yeah so
which is the average degree so let's try
to see some how to use this fact maybe
two to see what it gives us four for the
snows so four degrees of the notes so
maybe we can think about the flow into
the vertex V here as a proxy for degree
it so there is a problem with us and so
the issues that maximum flow is not
unique so the flow itself right so the
value is unique this is what we used
before where output but the maximum flow
is not unique
so what we would like to get is a unique
flow that has low global sensitivity ok
so how we're going to do this so we're
going to maximize a different function
so instead of maximizing the sum of the
flows we're going to maximize the sum of
some function of the flow and this
function is just going to be a concave
strictly concave function which is
strictly increasing on the interval from
0 to T so this is an example of such
such a function so maybe it's not very
important what the specific function is
it looks like this and this is what
we're going to maximize they still let
so consider the flow a few which
actually maximizes this expression right
so the sum of the dysfunction applied to
the flows here and let f star be the
vector that we get here this out vector
of s and this is what we're going to use
as a proxy for for the degree for the
degrees of the vertices so now at star
is unique because H is strictly concave
right so right so if i get to maximum
maximum then i can just use a linear
combination has to be higher musta had a
better value so i also can be computed
in polynomial time and thank you for
right to the session canal for they
up-to-date reference on the best
algorithm for this ok so and so this is
what we're going to do so let's see why
it works is it so again so this is the
flow which maximizes
written the session I guess yes okay
okay so so this is the flow that
maximizes this expression and so again
so that star is the flow that we get on
content on this edges and so for bounded
degree graph so with a degree bond d
this F star is actually a good proxy for
the degree it's exactly equal to the
degree and this is true because H is
strictly increasing on the centerville
right soon and so what we have to prove
is that a one global sensitivity of this
quantity so if we're in the way we
define the libris extensions way we have
to prove its at most 2 d but so we can
produce its most 3d and it's you know
just a still a good bound and the no is
it will have to it so this is the only
thing that remains to do it just to
prove that a one global sensitivity of
this is it most VD so let me give give
you just some intuition why it's true so
again to analyze the global sensitivity
we just compare two graphs their
neighbors and look at the corresponding
flow graphs for them so this is a liquor
so we had a node and we had the
corresponding and edges in the flow
graph is before and so let me call this
new edge here p sub s and this new edge
here p sub T so now let's consider so if
we take the new flow so the flow in this
new graph minus the old flow so let G be
the resulting flow function so it turns
out the G is a unit Union ok so the
metrons out so it's a so G's is a union
of simple st pats and cycles and there
are several types that
you have to consider so the first type
is st pats and cycles that used this
first edge right and so how much can
they contribute to changes in this f
star vector right so we're going to
measure the changes in terms of l1 norm
so they contributed most to d2 this to
the change in the vector so why is this
so if it's a path right so every unit of
flow it carries is going to change this
vector here by one right and if it's a
cycle right so I at most two right if it
goes back so together it's at most 2 d
ok so the second type of paths or so
work just here just work we don't be
going to get surges paths osc paths
which use ET this edge right so how much
do they contribute so they're just past
it so each of them each unit of flow
here is just going to well maybe it will
go for Hitler hear it so it with most
will contribute one to the change in the
vector of values and four cycles which
are using it t so it's going to be at
most 0 right because the cycles it's a
cycle is here it doesn't touch this
vector at all and if there was a cycle
that actually uses one of those edges it
would imply that there is in the cpap so
which would mean that this is not in
maximum flow and actually the flow that
I didn't mention this but the fellow
that we find is actually a maximum flow
so it's a mo 0 and so there are many
paths in cycles which don't use this to
new edges basically turns out you can
prove that they don't exist and now you
can prove it using a stricken cavity of
the function so here is the summary of
diagram so we can track the flow graph
then we compute this so instead of
computing the maximum flow will compute
the flow that maximizes
the sum of this concave functions apply
to lowes here and then we compute so
what we get here right so the s outflows
on honest and this is what we really is
just basically what Laplace noise 3d
over epsilon because the sequani has
global since they did 3d and after this
you can just use the known processing
techniques so I guess some of them
requires that you sort the values of the
vector before releasing and basically we
have very good post processing
techniques for removing some of the
noise in the degree sequences certainly
also in the degree sequence but also in
a degree distribution sasha modified
can you do something with just
ice flow as a new year program your
favorite way and you're being a little
bit then you know that would like
probably the presidential one max wiser
for instance your boy anymore yes I
guess you have to be also careful that
the global sincerity of the resulting
things are there there are two things we
need yes i'm a maybe some point is
because the original float maximum flow
the maximum fun the original program is
it you need right right basically what
your preservation is doing is picking
one right in a way you so but then the
question is you know can you control the
way in which is nick right so maybe
maybe music random perturbation there is
a nice way to do that but what we're
doing instead is picking a particular
maximum flow by adding a strictly
concave penalty right that's roughly
like taking you know i don't know the
centroid of the maximum flows or
something like something in the middle
of the set of my hunch was right where
middle is defined by the here's more
control if I bet maybe there's a meteor
which is an immature person is just look
at you that's what you have to analyze
this what yeah so there are two things
that we need rates in addition to uni
administrate so why do we want to make
and swim on this global sincerely to be
well but a minute oh my god that was so
I guess what we want in the end is
basically not uniqueness but the the the
global sincerely right so we want to
control so you know if it can now put
two different things so so basically
what can happen if you're just
outputting like any maximum flow it can
switch between one flow and a very
different flow which is going to have
very different values on the vectors
that will evaporate the bread pudding
which is going to result in high global
sense TV so you're Nick pneus is just
the way to the elvenhome remote user so
if you switch from one flow to an
arbitrary other roll it will change it
will change a lot right so that's that's
the point so I guess you want to control
how changes so uniqueness is
it's a way of controlling so you pick
the ones that don't difference so much
overall gaps not smooth low degree grams
its overall great shape but it's
actually think of something you send
easy and then two vertices one of degree
number two miles degree n over 2 minus
one you made one with and over to all
the citizens right right yeah so we know
that flows and really like any normal
way is not a good way to construct close
rates okay so how much more time do I
have / 10 minutes he said taken yeah so
one more method later so this is a
recursive mechanism and it was published
in the paper in sigmoid by Shinjo to
researchers from China um so let me try
to explain at a high level and so I'm
going to explain it for a specific
example and i found this paper very and
very challenging to read but it has very
it has nice ideas and it's so like it's
it is it is like challenging different
way it is formal and i guess they're a
little bit low an example so they
present everything at the very very
abstract level okay so um so what they
give is a strategy for releasing real
valued functions so we're going back to
so like one more examples if we're going
to be thinking about this the number of
triangles let's say again so we're going
to define a function let me just give
you an overview what we're going to try
to do if we're going to define a
function which they call X so X sub
Delta of our graph and again so
analogously to previous methods is going
to have low global society and so and so
as in the projection methods and also
it's going to be so in the projection
methods so the this values of LP
programs that we got were lower bound on
the actual value of the function so here
it's going to be the same story and the
larger Delta is going to be the closer
we're going to be to the
show value the same as we had in our
projection methods and then we're going
to release again similarly so this is
the analogy with build methods with the
previous method sorry excess of Delta
for kill carefully chosen delica via the
yellow class mechanism and again I'm not
not going to explain how to choose this
out even though and they explain but
it's a non-trivial part of the paper in
ok so how we're going to define the
sequence X sub Delta so before defining
the seconds we're going to find another
sequence of H sub i's so which are
functions of the graph and so the first
the 0 of 1 is equal to the 0 the last
one is equal to the function that we
want to release so let's keep thinking
about the number of triangles as our
example and in there correspond to this
and also the increasing functions the
one function that you can think about
they're so H sub I so it has to be it is
supposed to be cattle G H sub I've g is
the minimum over all sub graphs of the
given graph of the graph G so the
capital G which have I nodes so sighs I
mean they have I nodes what's the value
it was the minimum value of my function
so the number of triangles what's the
smallest number of triangles I can get
in the sub graph of my graph with i
knows ok so the property in order to use
the mechanism the properties of h is
that we want is they must be
interleaving and this is adam's name no
not there anything so what does it mean
so if we look at the H I of some grab g1
so sorry if we if we look for to a
neighboring graphs g1 and g2 where g one
is the smaller graph it's a g2's
obtained by adding one more node i think
the picture one more note from g1 and so
for all I so
we'll look at H on one of the smaller
graph it has to be sandwiched between H
I of G 2 and H I plus one of g2 so maybe
let's see why it holds for the specific
function and that we're looking at here
so if we look so maybe even possibly
possibly still let's take the number of
triangles as the example so if we look
at the number of triangles in the
smaller graph graph so we're looking the
number of triangles and sub graphs with
I nodes here right and here we're
looking at the number of triangles with
I nodes in the bigger graph right so and
this is the minimum function that we're
taking here so in particular we can
first remove this node right and then do
the same operation that we did here to
remove other nodes to obtain I nodes so
it's definitely going to be at most what
we could obtain here right and similarly
here so if we look at the number of
triangles so in this bigger graph versus
the smaller graph so now we're allowed
to remove the same number of nodes to
obtain to achieve this minimum right so
naturally here we're going to be less
than or equal than here the sequence
this choice of H eyes would work no
matter what graphs you have and what
pair of adjacent drats you have but the
way it's written here given a graph G
define a sequence with these properties
where the HSR interleaving that suggests
that the choice of the HS could depend
on the ground
so this is you mean so what's the order
of quantification for the triangles so
episode the the function at so you just
define a function so that each H I is a
function of the graph so the value
depends on the graph but if I furniture
cphi is it if I find a collection of H
is that works for a particular graph and
all of its neighbors will it will this
be good for all perhaps so basically yes
um so it has to so this property has to
hold for all graphs so it has to extend
to all its neighbors Rachel and
neighbors of neighbors if I have you
started with your graph G if I can
complete the other graph right the
choice of functions eh functions should
work for this other graph as well right
so you should work in what relates
things become different I F and they're
not to turn in Beijing your choice is
the h0 h1 h2 depend on earth but not on
g
yeah so the issues are like right so
their functions rate so basically so you
can choose the value of the function
depending on G it's a 4g there is a
separate value of the function right so
and so the reason to pick edges other
than for example this one would be that
for some apps other edge edges may be
better or maybe even for some families
we care about it okay just move it right
and so another reason which will come
back to if we have time is that this is
actually hard to compute its and be hard
to calculate say this is a their version
of inefficient recursive mechanism and
is it far more or less okay all right so
so once we have this interleaving
functions so now we're going to define
this quantity that we care about the
phone quantity that we're going to try
to release which will have low levels of
silly and this quantity itself to its a
minimum over all H I of G so but here so
we add the penalty function so the lower
below is I so the more nodes will remove
from our graph they hire the penalty so
the penalty is proportional to Delta
great and so it's times the number of
nodes we're moving to get this so that's
the function so it's um it's a it's
different like it's not like I guess
exactly projection and so we're going to
to show that it has low global
sensitivity mean Delta for Delta right
and and moreover so we can see that so
this quantity is actually equal to the
value of the function as long as they'll
pay stuff is sufficiently large it's a
what is sufficiently large mean so it
means that one will go to a lord i right
when we're removing one more node the
value of the function um does not change
by more than delta
so somewhat related to this down since
is it anything but now I'm just I'm not
going into details Regional Council cv
he so basically there is some good dealt
out there which so basically the lower
you make the Delta the lower your global
sensitivity but you might eventually
lose this property that you're going to
be equal to your function and eventually
you're going to go lower and lower in
your lower bonds so there is a similar
type trade-off to previous methods okay
so so this is what and the summary of
what we have so each eyes must be
interleaving this is what it means and
so this is how this function X of Delta
is defined and so I didn't want to
mention briefly why the Global's and I'm
running up 10 right so why the global
sensitivity of X sub delta is equal to
Delta so how would we let me just
quickly go over the perp so consider the
neighbors such that you want is a
subgraph of g 2 so what we want to show
is in two directions so the first
direction is that on the bigger grab the
value of this function is less than or
equal to the value on the small graph
plus delta and to do this you can just
use the idea into a living property so
this is the whole proof of this
direction so let a star be the index
that minimizes the expression for X
Delta on the smaller graph and then
let's see how we can upper bound their X
sub Delta of g2 on the larger graph so
if so the expression for Delta is the
minimum so in particular if we have
substitute I star there it's going to be
less than or equal to then the
corresponding expression and so here
just we have n plus 1 because it's a
graph on n plus many nodes and now we
just write this out here and here we
just use the interleaving property so
we're going to a smaller graph so
because wanting H is going to be my
upper bound and this is just equal so
this part is equal by definition to X
Delta
to surplus so that's the proof and
basically it's a very similar proof you
can just show that X Delta G 1 is less
than or equal to X Delta eg to and so in
fact here you don't even need Delta it's
a kind of on smaller glass drops it
smaller so that's that's all in terms of
global succeeding and so let me mention
one more thing so the example of the
function that I gave yours it isn't be
hard to complete right so this is not
going to lead to an efficient algorithm
the natural idea is to use an Opie
relaxation put this H is and again it's
not very hard to do so basically just by
the high level let's say for the number
of triangles what can we do so we're
just going to write a linear program
which captures the number of triangles
and we're just going to relax it so
we're going to minimize for overall
triangles of G right so we're you the n
double your triangles sorry we're going
to have a variable for each node this
time for each node and at that and so
we're going to minimize its expression
so if just doesn't matter which
expression is here basically if the
values are actually zeros and ones
that's going to compute it's going to
output one if the triangle is there so
if it's going to help with one and if a
case one of them is zero is just going
to 0 civilization of the end function so
these are the variables and the only
other constraint is that the sum of this
variables has to be equal to I right so
we're looking i knows an integral so
that's basically that's the algorithm
right so they use this efficient version
of h is and now they compute X Delta and
I would've using global since Terry
framework modular this thing that I
didn't explain how to choose the right
Delta ok so that's the summary so what I
try to explain is three
the new techniques and I explain them in
the note sensitivity as they apply to
not sin city but they also improve edge
differentially private algorithms so
it's truncation plus mu sensitivity
Lipschitz extensions and recursive
mechanism the unifying idea is some kind
of projections I guess for the for the
recursive mechanism is a stretch to
think about this projection when some
kind of graph so this linear programs
are not exactly graphs but and low
sensitivity is kind of this term may be
down sensed it is a good thing to think
about so I explained their generic
reductions to privacy / bounded degree
graphs which use truncation plasmosis TV
releasing the number of edges and sub
graph counts using lipsius extensions
via max flow and linear programming
releasing degree distribution using
elections extension be a convex
programming and releasing its a Brad
pounds using the recursive mechanism of
chain and gel and so i'm not going to i
guess spend any time on this but there
are some experiments has been done so my
so an undergraduate student and penn
state working with me Edward Lou
evaluated our algorithms which is
flowing linear programming and basically
so these are real graphs and you can see
that some of them are quite big grass
and basically even you know for
releasing the number of edges you get
pretty good error even / smoker epsilon
so so this log scale and this is for the
number of triangles and I guess the
running times so for flow programs even
for huge graphs they're small here
there's some weirdness in terms of Helen
and think so this is almost three hours
this is half an hour but you know he
didn't customize anything here she just
ended like took off the shelf LP package
and just used it just them ok so um so
basically you know the point is that
they're there they can be used they I
guess if you have a couple of hours you
can output simple statistics and you
know then maybe add reasonable noise on
the CTA rail e-cigarettes which are
social networks which are
from Stanford collections like our
collections to their experiments also in
the recursive mechanism paper they
mostly run them on smaller graphs and it
just appears so we didn't implement
their album but it just appears that
their algorithms take too long to turn
on big graphs because so they're running
times or in ours also um so let me just
skip us and so conclusions so we're
close to having edge private and no
private algorithms that work well in
practice for at least basic graph
statistics we have interesting
projection type technique so that might
be useful for designing differentially
private algorithms in other contexts not
only for graphs and so the next thing
that I have is a bunch of open problems
but I don't know if you want you to cut
me off or let me list them talk about oh
man okay so some open so I have two
slides up on open problems so the first
type is a new technique so this is kind
of respect to what I talked about today
so first question is can special purpose
so P solvers make the techniques more
efficient so and as I said like they're
not optimized in any way that he just
took off the shelf so that's out there
on this run running so to which other
queries do they apply into was the best
way to choose the decreased cuddle for
sin city qualify as I said I swept it
under the rug we have some way of
choosing it's not clear it gives the
best way so like also in the experiments
that ad ran there were like much better
this so like basically I do I show this
for fixed d so specific queries that
it's worth thinking about so releasing
cuts with no differential privacy so we
know how to release them with edge
differential privacy but there is quite
high there so even when you go to
bounded degree graphs it produces too
too mature to give you a meaningful
answer so even just multiplying the
everyone by D gives you something to
hide then the question that or really
want me to put oven personal
one for me dimensions so there is a
challenge in terms of releasing
something really anything related to
distances so any kind of sensitivity
measure seems to be high and just you
know goes to infinity like quickly like
if you remove one now let's say so so
there is a challenge there yesterday I
guess at some point with yeah we thought
about how to define it like maybe some
related measures which are more a bus
but there's a challenge there iam so
what else so the differentially private
private synthetic graft so I mentioned a
one paper by Rebecca really where she
did it under some assumptions rates a
bit um it's a pretty much an explored
very much an explored area simultaneous
release of answers to many queries so
we'll have it for normal databases but
note that grats you don't get it in
standard database open on grass what are
the right notions of privacy for grab
data so it's also maybe there are some
other interesting notion so I'm very
briefly mentioned notions of people were
exploring like the zero knowledge
differential privacy where the right
ways to state utility guarantees so
again I didn't talk about it much so but
there are so people do stuff people are
starting to analyze the CT the utility
branches of the graph so for the South
Graham so it's challenging it's
challenging because they are not doing
well in the worst case maybe you have to
think how to phrase it that they're
doing well for real graphs and in which
sense they are doing well okay so I add
an absolute sense or you know with
respect to some locals as Sydney
measures like the sounds in saving so
now the question social networks have
node and edge attributes so what queries
are useful so and I know that the
Christine is thinking about these
questions you had the question example
in your paper were you use node
attributes like simple note attributes
may be like genders so what queries do
social scientists fine
useful what else what would be like a
store nice privately and finally
hypergraphs so so far we talked about
graphs which capture relationships
between pairs of people but now we can
capture relationships between groups of
people so for example people appearing
on the same photo it could be a
relationship so can really statistics
for hypergraph sorry your sympathy it
might be interesting it's a clustering
clustering so wats and coefficients and
not just what sequestering coefficients
in sebacean transitivity but there's
also clustering in the sense of here is
a group of friends can i pick out which
clump is the republicans in which club
does the democrats so in that sense
modularity in his lab different metrics
for this and it's very difficult to do
with differential privacy somebody was
using differentially private spectral
analysis which is used for clustering
and I haven't actually read the paper
okay I guess I i guess i didn't find
related the paper and but uh yes yeah
there's no small oh it's very
challenging so so something related to
clustering thank you and what would your
out with me I so your output could be we
found six groups for instance here their
relative sizes approximately and if you
had known attributes to work with you
could say we think this group is likely
interested in this group is I clinched
in that and so on and preferably if you
could you would say this group is more
tightly connected to these other two
groups than this
such as the sizes would be good recent
your second interesting
yes I guess if you right so I guess if
you look at with respect to H privacy
does something like it basically skills
sensitivity proportional to the number
to the number of ya connections that you
have so in some sense it's doing with
what you want all ready to like if it
yeah if you just say you know it's going
to be proportional to
thank you sir yes that's kind of like
like saying ensure privacy to the change
we found another avenges other thing I
guess something that so if you mentioned
that you know may have been lost is that
these projection type techniques they
give you accuracy even bridge wasn't
lost yes I I didn't I didn't go over
experiments but the show hnng up a paper
they actually show that there I mean the
experiment with a recursive mechanism
with respect to edge privacy and they
show that it's doing better than so our
paper on releasing crab counts for most
ways on which they should so again so
there is probably some bottleneck in
terms of running time because they
techniques we use ur very fast but they
had they end up adding more I'd any more
noise it's galen
you